we are here to announce the indictment
of alexander cote
and al-shafi al-shaikh kotei and
al-shaikh were members of the
notoriously brutal
isis hostage-taking cell that became
known as the beatles
a name their captives gave to them
because of their british accents
the defendants are charged with
terrorism offenses related to
hostage-taking and killing of four
americans
as well as citizens of great britain
and japan for over a year cote and
al-shaikh were held in iraq by the u.s
military under the law of armed conflict
i'm pleased to confirm that they are now
in fbi custody
and will soon appear in federal court in
the eastern district of virginia
today is a good day but it is also
a solemn one today
we remember the four innocent americans
whose lives
were taken by isis james
wright foley stephen
joel sotloff
peter edward kasich
and kayla gene mueller
many around the world are familiar with
the barbaric circumstances of their
deaths
but we will not remember these americans
for the way they died
we will remember them for the way they
lived their good
and decent lives james foley was a print
and video journalist who is covering the
civil war in syria
he had previously served as a conflict
zone correspondent in iraq
and then in libya james was a former
elementary school teacher steven sotloff
was a journalist who covered the middle
east and was in syria
reporting on the refugee crisis
according to a longtime friend he was
drawn to the region to quote
give a voice to the people who didn't
have one close quote
stephen was the grandson of holocaust
survivors who
inspired him to be that voice peter
kassig was in syria working for a
humanitarian organization that he
founded to deliver
food and medical aid to the refugees he
had previously served as an elite
airborne ranger
in the u.s army which included service
in iraq
kayla mueller was a humanitarian aid
worker and human rights activist
who inspired by her faith devoted much
of her young life to serving those in
need
both at home and abroad as president
trump shared during his 2020 state of
the union address
the american warriors who conducted the
military operation
that resulted in the death of isis
leader abu bakr al-baghdadi
were in so inspired by kayla that they
named the mission
task force 814 a reference
to august 14th kayla's birthday
today's announcement is the result of
many years of hard work in the pursuit
of justice for these americans
we have been inspired by their memories
and moved by the determination and
grit of their families families which
will never rest
until justice is done to them
i say this neither will we
although we cannot bring back your
children we will do
all that we can obtain justice for them
for you and for all americans
as for cote and i'll shake like many
other terrorists before them
they have underestimated the american
resolve to obtain
justice for our fellow citizens who are
harmed or killed by terrorists anywhere
in the world
these men will now be brought before a
united states court to face justice for
the depraved acts alleged against them
in the indictment as for their
ringleader mohammed emwazi
infamously known as jihadi john
he faced a different kind of american
resolve the mighty reach of our military
which successfully targeted him in an
airstrike several years ago
my message to other terrorists is this
if you harm an american
you will face the same fate as these men
you will face american arms in the
battle
battlefield and if you survive that
you will face american justice in an
american courtroom
and the prospect of many years in an
american prison
either way you will never live in peace
you will be pursued to the ends of the
earth no matter how long it takes
we will never forget we will never quit
to the american people today's
announcement is a reminder of the threat
that we continue to face from radical
islamic terrorism these terrorists
despise the freedoms and the way of life
we cherish
and are hell-bent on imposing their
ideologies on a world
that continues to reject them although
our nation
faces a variety of national security
threats from many quarters
we will not relent in our efforts to
protect america
and her citizens from the threat posed
by terrorists
today's announcement would not have been
possible without the relentless effort
of countless dedicated prosecutors
agents and analysts who are the bedrock
of the department of justice
i want to thank the prosecutors from the
u.s attorney's office of the eastern
district of virginia
from my own national security division
and all of the many
fbi agents and analysts who have worked
tirelessly on this case
i also want to thank the office of
international affairs and the united
states attorney's office for the
southern district of new york
both of which assisted with important
aspects of this investigation
the attorney general wanted me to convey
that the support
of the united kingdom's home secretaries
sajid javid
and priddy patel was critical to moving
this investigation
and prosecution forward and he extends
his sincerest gratitude
for their unwavering commitment to the
pursuit of justice
in this case we also want to thank all
of our international partners who have
come forward thus far with evidence
and i would encourage any others with
evidence to come forward as well
we understand that the justice we seek
in this case will extend to many people
in numerous other countries
around the world and we humbly
and enthusiastically accept that
responsibility
we all have our part to do our part in
confronting
and defeating isis just last week the
department announced our significant
successes
in repatriating and prosecuting a number
of u.s citizens who went to syria to
join and support isis
and were detained by the syrian defense
the democratic forces
the united states has been a leader in
taking responsibility for its citizens
who left to join isis and
as the case we are announcing today
highlights when we have the evidence to
do so
we will also take responsibility for
prosecuting those non-u.s citizens
who have injured or killed americans
anywhere in the world
if you have american blood in your veins
or you have american blood on your hands
you will face american justice
this department has successfully
prosecuted hundreds of defendants since
9 11
for terrorism-related offenses in our
federal courts and we will continue to
do so
finally i want to acknowledge the
departments of state and the department
of defense
we will continue to work together with
them and our other partners in the u.s
government
to combat the scourge of terrorism